you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 1 of
6 from the 1997 rematch between Gary
Kasparov and IBM supercomputer deep blue
this first game Kasparov has the white
side it opens with Knight f3 deeply
responding with d5 and 2 Kasparov now
going with a kingside fee and keto
Bishop g4 and also a queen side fiend
keto my d7 Bishop b2 and pay close
attention to this 'if I've Square and
the reason I bring this up is because
you'll know in the early stage white is
always in a position to do one of two
things a prevent black from getting in
this e5 advance or be meeting in a v
advance with E for why is this important
it's important because if black is able
to get upon an e5 well that next step
that that pon wants to go to is of
course efore where it would hit the
night and the Knight has to run away to
square that maybe it doesn't want to
have to run away to there might not be a
better square than f3 in short a
complete domino effect can occur on the
white side I could turn out very bad if
white is not responding in the center or
fighting for what's known as your fair
share in the center if black has upon e
5 you better be in a position to strike
at it with e4 so E 6 is played and for
the most part getting the minor pieces
out and getting castled in this very
early stage Knight f6 white castle's c6
reinforces d5 it well since this pawn is
protected this becomes more more of a
possibility and eventually 5 advanced d3
Knights looking at that D 2 square more
directly watching over a 4 as well
Bishop d6 92 black castles h3 and the
bishop runs back to h5 east III is a bit
of an interesting move or maybe maybe
not so much
Kasparov playing against this computer
not really so welcome to an open type of
position more open the position the more
possibilities and the more possibilities
the better off the computer will be has
no issue of course with running any
amount of calculations another another
way to view it is well if you're going
to be playing something like e for I
mean it's a move that could be played
but you know you're you're opening up
the position again against computer and
you're also still in a pin right here
you're still having to battle out of a
pin you're opening the position up bad
things can happen very very quickly so
something to really steer clear of it's
a little bit of a waiting game I think
as well with this III advance trying to
still look for some close type of
position h3 flight square for that black
King Queen e1 gets out of the pin and is
looking for something like Knight h2
soon enough we see that after Queen a5
first a3 a lot of pawns on this third
rank a lot of controls is extremely
white has a lot of control over the
fourth rank and another curious thing
that I came across in this game is that
white just plays on these first three
rings for I think really the majority of
the game at some point we do eventually
ce4 or extremely 5 and then e4 but
beyond that there's a whole lot of
shuffling that takes place on these
first three ranks a lot of maneuvering
goes on in this game so after a three we
have I get some maneuvering by black as
well I'm not really I can't really put
my finger on what Bishop c7 is doing I
guess it stays out of the way of a I
guess a potential fork with this pawn
getting to e5 or maybe looking to get on
this diagonal not really sure what
Bishop c7 is doing still I guess a
somewhat of a waiting game night age 4
is looking to get this
f-pawn involved and we see now the
computer playing g5 which is probably
not one of the top candidate moves you
would see can human really considering
weakening the king position in a
tremendous way f6 h6 in particular at a
moment where you already have a dark
square Bishop breathing down your neck
this is something that is very crazy to
see a human doing but the computer could
run all the calculations that of course
has no fear
so after g5 Knight comes back and now we
have some action in the center a five is
now met with E for fighting for white is
fighting for their fair share in the
center and for a handful of moves we
just see these pawns in tension with one
another white will always be in a spot
to be meeting D takes e with D takes e
so getting the other rook involved
reinforcing a central point e v Knight H
to the start of some repositioning
ideally this night would like to make
use of f1 and then get to g3 so that
this pond will eventually be needing to
move and it's interesting to see how
black makes that not so not so easy to
get in Queen b6 for starters paves the
way for this a pond to get involved it
also observes something which is
unprotected on b2 and of course it is
opposite that white king so Queen c1 the
start of repositioning the Queen needs
to move before the rook can move and the
rope needs to move before the Knights
can make use of f1 a5 gaining some space
on the Queen side and since this pond is
on a3
the the move a4 while the knee-jerk
reaction to something like a 4 is going
to be B for keeping things closed so
rook to e1 Bishop d6 looking at this c5
square you'll note that after the rook
is played to e1 this f2 square is a bit
soft
the Queen is hitting it excuse me the
Queen is hit
once the king is defending it once it's
right now you could say unprotected one
attacker one defender so with Bishop d6
it's looking to get at that weak point
Knight f1 the tension is now resolved in
the center D take C D take C and now
Bishop to c5 putting more pressure on f2
but just in time is Kasparov worth
defending against it with the night to
e3 getting the last piece involved is
deep blue with rook on a to d8 and now
Knight to f1 and if black is not
accurate at this point I think that
Kasparov couldn't obtain a strategic of
a very good strategic advantage which is
to say the continuation let me just make
a a nothing type of move if we were to
see King g7 we could have something like
g4 the bishop of course has to react and
then Knight g3 and you'll note that
White has the possibility of getting
into that f5 square and this Bishop is
just kind of out of play it's difficult
to get it working this bishop could
maybe always come about by way of f1 I
think this would be a very strong
position for white to get into still a
closed position on the Kings side and
then stuff can happen on the Queen side
this Bishop is in my mind it starts to
be a big issue it's not really
contributing at all so this is not
allowed we were not seeing King g7 but
instead g4 but I believe that that would
be the strategical this is the
strategical threat to trying to get in
g4 if you try to do that one thing
that's interesting is that if you're
trying to get in this g4 move right now
well it doesn't come in time because
you'll know after the bishop place of g6
white is now having to react to e4
if this Knight was already this Knight
was already on f1 if when the bishop
goes to g6 the night plays to g3 and is
defending that e4 square for a second
time so it's just it's not
happening in time if g4 is being played
right now but with the night on f1 it is
being threatened
black addresses that with g4 H takes G
Knight takes G and F 3 was a little
crazy for me to see when I was first
reviewing this game just you know
welcoming an absolute pin I'm at e3
knight Knight takes Knight takes and
Bishop to e7 okay there's still this pin
and with this Bishop e7 move deep blue
is looking to still place that night in
a pin just on a different diagonal and I
believe indirectly looking at that D 2
square at some point I think getting a
rip to that second rank would be of
course a very good thing so has a couple
things I believe in mind by making use
of g5 so first first things first get
out of the pin King h1 Bishop g5 rope -
E - looking to eventually get the Queen
off of this diagonal there's actually a
couple pins going on with rookie - not
only is the knight pinned but so too is
this pot on f3 which is something that
black looks to exploit but first we have
some action on the Queen side a4 is met
with B for keeping things closed in now
f5 coming right at white opening up the
position or at least trying to open it
up a bit more where white is in the site
where white is the side that's in these
uncomfortable pins the night and this
pawn takes fe4 is played pressure on
that F pawn but we just have f4 giving
up this rook we do have Bishop takes
rook right away and this is this is one
point in the game where I thought well
why not first maybe take this pawn on f4
let's let's have a quick look at why
maybe that was not played first and the
reason it wasn't played is because after
G takes Bishop Bishop takes rook we
would have the very calm but
the deadly Queen to d2 hitting up the
bishop and also threatening to just get
on this highly weakened diagonal this
dark square diagonal if for example the
bishop reacts by playing to h5 Queen c3
what do you do about the Queen getting
to g7 just showing one continuation if
Righi seven to defend we could have
first night c4 hitting the Queen Queen
to c7 and now we could land a Czech King
here land another check this is not
necessarily the best continuation but I
believe it's clear enough to see that at
this point after Queen takes pawn
the threat of grabbing the bishop and
also giving Czech here is going to be
favourable for why our just winning for
white I should say black at this point
is completely busted and needing to give
back a lot of material at least minor
piece at this point if the bishop is
reacting 96 the Queen has to give
herself up so we're not seeing that at
this point that's why at this point
right right here after f4 we're not
seeing Bishop takes f4 but instead just
Bishop takes rook so black who is with
this last sequence of moves really going
for material which is maybe one of the
downsides for the computer putting too
much of a value on material F takes G
and now Knight to e5 this is another
point pawn takes is killed right away
with pick your favorite square Knight c4
or d5 both of which would be hitting
that Queen if the knight is taken we
just have a million three the Queen and
Bishop both converging on g7 with this
pawn around it's going to be leading to
mate Queen blocks you just take mate
nothing you could do so that's why we're
not having it takes G there of course
because of the knight move to one of
those two but instead Knight e5 trying
to reduce this bishops mobility getting
the rook involved as well
but now with g6 we have connected past
pawns
this could be this could turn out to be
very dangerous very quickly
Bishop EFT Bishop f3 Bishop to c3
keeping a close eye on d2 ruling out the
possibility for the rope to make use of
that second rank
Queen b5 and Cass prop now just looking
to get rid of the Queen's and that
happens Queen takes rook takes h5
unfortunately for black there's not
really a whole lot that can be done here
this pawn in particular and Bishop are
controlling or I should say doing a very
good job in controlling entry points
that this rook might have it's on an
open file but where where can it go next
it's not really able to pivot on any
square where it could function laterally
so h5 is played King g1 gets out of the
pin King f8 and again for the most part
it's just a lot of shuffling on the
black side Bishop h3 b5 rules out any
night c4 ideas for example if we did
have something like rip to rook to d7
let me just point out the reasons why
we're not having let's say rook moves
where we're having King moves because if
you move the rooks you'll know moving
this rook is what allows upon advance
with tempo similarly if this rook moves
upon advance with tempo and well where
else is there to go if you go to if you
go to d6 could always grab the knight
and then make use of that c4 square at
the fork so again not really a whole lot
to do after Bishop h3 b5 does take away
that possibility of a potential fork
with first grabbing the knight but we
just have deep blue making a whole lot
of King moves in a position where it's
it's hard to make any improvements these
ponds are very very strong g4 is the
break this Knight is now in a pin if the
King was not making use of g7
we could still have this g4 move coming
about white is able to provide an
additional supporter for its advance but
King g7 is tried g4 King h6 gets out of
the pin rook g1 a bunch of exchanges on
g4 and after the smoke clears a very
basic endgame black is still up the
exchange but again these pawns these
connected past pounds are invaluable
ripp d6
hitting at f5 the main threat here for
white is really to just play to f6 and
then play to h4 which is going to be
main so that's being addressed with rook
and d5 f6 is played there's no reason to
not keep pushing those pawns rip d1 and
after g7 we have deep blue resigning
this first game of six there's no way to
prevent GA equaling Queen or combination
of f7 however you slice it these pawns
will be promoting and the rooks are
going to have to get themselves up so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye